hello everybody and welcome you all
so it's a very exciting day because
today we're going to talk about
one of the very interesting topic of the
react.js and that is not called working
with the react context
so we will talk about the introduction
like what is the react context
when to use react context context apis
and the demo
so the intention of this particular
presentation is to give you the correct
idea in react what benefit you utilize
it or you get it when you use a context
context api
now the first question is like
in an existing react application
okay where the context ap is really
useful
so let's talk about some introduction to
react context
now first important thing we need to
understand a typical application when we
talk about react application so data is
always pass through what from the top
down approach
with the help of props as we know it
very well
if we have a component like an a b and c
and if c components wants to get the
data from
a so a cannot directly pass the data to
c because
c is the child of b and b is the child
of a so according to the rule so data
has to be
passed through the proper hierarchy that
is called drilling down the props
which is one of the very very
complicated area because when you have a
complex hierarchy and if you are making
a lot of middlemen in between so this
create a lot of confusion in your
development and hence your application
gets more and more complex
so to avoid such kind of scenarios so we
have this option like in
react context so in context api what
happens like here
the data can be passed directly
to any of the component whichever
needs that
so data gets stored in a centralized
environment and from there it get passed
down to all its child whenever it needs
whether it is a direct child or it is a
indirect
so this is what the benefit you get with
the help of props here
so if you see the main comments have got
not many childs so using the props you
are passing the data to all its child
directly
but the challenge here is that all
childs are direct child of main
component what in case if we have
further
childs so that create a lot of trouble
okay so create context is basically the
way where you can pass a data directly
to
the components and cut down the all
middlewares
okay to your applications
and that's what the context api and the
question is like when to use a context
api
so as you can see it is clearly written
like context is basically designed
to be considered as a global state which
any of the components tree can easily
get it directly from its parent
okay without involving any of itself
directly
now
you see like here we have a call app
component which have the language as a
function
and here we have a call select language
so you are passing the data here to its
child
okay so you see here the language
component needs to take a very important
extra component that is known as call
what lang
and pass it to the selected language so
this could be further painful or more
complicated when on every single button
if the app needs to know the language
and what it is pass through the other
components so we want to basically cut
down all
so context if you want to use it
okay with using this areas like a
react.createcontext
so this create context helps you to
create a context in a parent component
whichever you want and let other
components subscribe to this so whenever
the changes are happened
they would be immediately informed about
that so here we have a call provider so
here every single context
okay so comes with a react
provider so they are basically trying to
consume the state whichever is being
available with the context
so using this property like in class or
context type you actually consume the
nearest current
of the context with using this dot
context
now we will call consumer
so this particular component which is
actually subscribing to the changes
okay so this let you
basically subscribe to the context with
a functional component and here you have
a call context or display name it
basically accept a display name as a
string property
okay which you can easily drag through
when you talk about react dev tools
now let's talk about a demo
of our development
so now here
let's get involved on the demo part
but before that i would like to show you
one simple problem statement which you
feel it so this if you see we've got
context api which is available here so
here you can see this is
a property drilling where you have
called parent you have further childs
and you have further childs so the
component properties are keep on going
through multiple mediators
which you want to avoid
okay and the right hand side if you see
this one is basically the parent and
immediately passed on to her to the
child
and you see like here it is happening
this is the wrong approach where the
data is basically going in the waterfall
model
this is better because here the data has
been passed from parent to any other
child directly
so that's what the benefit you get it
okay everybody so it's time to basically
talk about some
quick demo so that it can help us to
understand how we can utilize this react
context api for our development
so here
uh this is my project which is there
already developed
in my browser
i just when i open up i see here
in local 3000
i'm getting this as a welcome message
so nothing fancy let's get started with
creating a new component i'm creating a
new folder
when you call
components and insert this i'm going to
create a new file
and give the name anything whichever i
want i say
index
dot
js or else i can give some different
name called
main app.js that looks fine
well here i need to import
okay import
react from react
well let's go back and start developing
a function so i'm developing
function
app
because i'm talking about functional
component
return
okay
and within this tab tag i'm using this
h2 tag
and now here we are saying
welcome to app component
okay so that's a just a basic example we
have it
going ahead i would like to add few more
components like
function
employee
and the same thing
return
and here once again
okay
and here once again i'm saying h2
welcome to
employee component
okay
so
like this i can copy
and have one more that is called
salary and i'm saying
welcome to salary component
so these are the basic component sets
which are available to me
now certainly you will be having some
parent
and accordingly you can have some childs
also
so we have to make some components as a
parent so what i will do here is
in my app here
i will make
employee
here
i would like to make
okay
that means employees are com child of
app and
salary is a child of employee component
okay so it's very very simple
and straightforward
and later on
i can have
the new component ready
in which i can deploy
this
and make it available to the
end user
okay
so let's see what i'm having it now
so
here we have a call app
and here we are saying um
finally
equal to
i just use the name called main app
that looks more better
maina
and here we are using
react
dom
so we want to basically render it
wherever you want it
so what else what we can do is on the
other side
we can say
export
default
main app
we can do like this in this menu i can
add it under my
app.js file
so it came from here and let's check
well i got this message printed here
so
this is
very simple and straightforward like you
in creating a parent and child
relationship
so now
the actual job comes
when my application is having
some of the details which i'm looking at
it
okay that means i want to have a data so
as i said earlier that when you are
creating
the react based component so you need to
have some
relationships where the data can be
stored in anywhere so in the next
example i will show you how to store the
data in a main and how we can pass it to
the others
now we will be providing the data to our
main component
which is my main app
so here i would like to provide
const
here we can have
because we're talking about state
management
so we're using employee
employee
equal to
use
state
use state
and here in our use state will provide
some of the important information like
an id
suppose i say one zero one
and i say name
and i can just give the name called
admin and
so we have a call id we have a con name
let's try to
[Music]
put it
okay
it has to be here
yeah id
name admin and now we're talking about
location
we can say pune
and uh let's talk about
salary
and we can give any satellite like one
two three four five so
here we have got this uh quick
state which we have created
okay so the next thing is like once your
state is ready
okay so you have to provide some input
through which the data can be available
to the others
and to make this possible
here
above this we are providing
const
employee context
equal to
react.createcontext
so we are initializing our context
to confirm
what we're really doing this now
and in this context whichever i'm having
it now i would like to provide a data
which i can easily access to my other
components
so now here once i provide a context
here
okay so when i see this welcome to this
component you can see we have called
employee available
yeah so what i will be doing is now here
we will be saying
employee context
we see employee context
dot
provider
okay
now here
we want to provide
we close this
yeah so here we're providing value
value equal to
the value object so what value object we
are having it right now here
that is called employee
so this is state we are initially
providing it here
and
this
area wherever the context is basically
available will be providing this
employee object and pass it within this
so this employee object which we are
having it
so now you can see the context is closed
here so now within this context we have
passed as employee so the all data will
be available to this employee object now
and that's the best part of this code
now
okay
now this context i can easily get it
in my employee
okay
and access all the details whichever i
wanted now if i see here
i can come down and i say
let
context
equal to
now we are using this option i can use
context and insert this use context we
are talking about
employee context so we got the details
whatever we have set it on the top
okay and here
i can set
the details like we are saying welcome
to the employee
so we have got a lot many things
available here so
label
so let's provide the details here
so we are saying employee id
colon
here
we can use the details
okay by saying
context dot you can see we have got
details available
like an id
likewise i can just copy it
paste it
employee name
typical employee name
so we also have a part of this
id name location so we can also pass
location
okay
so we have got those
details available with us
and in a similar line
whatever details we have taken it from
there i can also pass it where
in my salary component too
where i can display the salary related
details into my code so like here
i can just copy this here
okay so we got employee context which is
available
and here i can provide the same number
of amount
like but this time
i may require sorry
i may require the name
as well as the salary both
okay
so these two details
whichever you want you can easily get it
and make it available to the client
okay so this using use context
you're actually trying to retrieve all
the relevant information
which was required and you can see it is
available here so the same employee
which is there now i can have this
employee details
under my employee component and under my
salary
we have a call salary component so
that's something which makes
your context api more interesting
because this is where you avoid
bringing any middleware and make this
data
or component easily accessible outside
so hope you're clear what context api is
all about and why we use it
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here